we begin this half-hour with a verdict
in a controversial case last April in
suburban Detroit a teenager got lost on
his way to school
and knocked on a door to ask for
directions the homeowner opened the door
armed with a shotgun and fired at the
teen as he ran for his life dean
reynolds has more on the case
where many field race was a factor
security video shows 14 year old brennan
walker approaching a stranger's house in
Rochester Hills Michigan last April I
knocked on the lady's door then she
started yelling at me and she was like
why you tend to break into my house and
I was trying to explain to her that I
was trying to get directions to
Rochester high he had overslept
missed the school bus and got lost
walking to class
he hoped home owner Dana Ziegler might
point him in the right direction why he
Sprint's away becomes clear in the next
frames that's 53 year old Jeffrey
Ziegler toting a 12-gauge shotgun aiming
and firing at the fleeing teenager the
shot missed him he grabbed the gun and I
saw it started surround and then that's
when I heard the gunshot
Dana Ziegler called 911 screaming as
loud as I possibly could he didn't look
like a child he was a brother big man
standing there and also if he was going
to school we have no schools in our area
the teens mother said race must have
played a role watching the tape you can
hear the wife say why did these people
choose my house for these people and
that's what that set me off police
detective Shaun pace recalled what he
told Ziegler during his interrogation
and Ziegler's response just admit that
you aimed your weapon at this young man
and he took a big drink of water
he looked at me and he says I'm tired
being a victim Ziggler who said his
house has had five previous break-ins
was questioned by his attorney in court
on Thursday
absolutely and on Friday the jury agreed
finding Ziggler guilty of assault he'll
be sentenced next month for CBS this
morning Saturday Dean Reynolds Chicago I
grew up in suburban Detroit it breaks my
heart to see a story like this yeah it
really does
it's just unbelievable standing on your
doorstep in the green and weather shock